average training sales and training
their sales teams backwards rather than
teach people about the products you
should be teaching them about the
prospect because if you understand the
prospect you can sell whatever you want
if you understand the product you're
going to be talking about features the
entire time and not listening to what
problems this person has and so all the
education 80 90 should be about who we
are selling to the problems that they
are suffering from rather than the
products that we are trying to push
because if you can perfectly articulate
someone's pain to them they will buy
whatever you recommend to them because
they feel understood rather than trying
to get them to understand what you have
it's about empathy not teaching